I'm here with Professor Laurence Baker
who's a professor here at Stanford
Medical School and what are we going to
talk about well we pay physicians a lot
of different ways in this country and I
thought it'd be useful to spend a minute
thinking about the different ways that
we do that the concepts organizations
different practices that are out there
so literally how do physicians receive
their compensation yes okay yes so we
can go through this in a couple of
different ways but there are three ways
that we can start out talking about
three general ways that we organize the
payment of physicians and they turn out
to be fee-for-service fee-for-service
let me write this fee sore for so keep
going fee-for-service ketchup yes
sometimes we say ffs fee first half ffs
okay makes sense and second one we call
capitation okay and the third one of
course salary too close to decapitation
for me but maybe it's an elated but okay
and then salary and then salary okay and
and so fee-for-service that seems to be
a little bit common sense what is is
that literally it like fee-for-service
in a fee-for-service system physician
gets paid a fee for every service that
they do it's kind of like going to a
restaurant you know you order the drink
your salad maybe an entree a dessert
this restaurant keeps a list of all the
things that you ordered and at the end
of the night there's a price associated
with each one and you add up the price
associated with each of the things you
got that makes your total bill that's
the fee for service I see and so this is
kind of what a doctor to private
practice would face well doctors and
doctors can be paid fee for service in a
lot of different objects so they might
be in private practice paid this way
some physician groups are paid this way
and fee-for-service concepts come up
even in large organizations like the
Stanford Medical School where some
people are sometimes paid for the work
in the hospital of course I see what the
general idea is if they're not providing
service or there's a slow day then
they're not going to be making money
that day right right the more services
they do the more expensive services they
do the more obviously they do the more
revenue that their practice will
generate I see and we'll talk later of
whether that's a good idea
yeah of course has it has implications
for the way right right
act and the way right so what's what's
capitation because that's that's I'm not
familiar with that so capitation the
general idea is to do something quite
different than fee-for-service the term
capitation comes from the latin per head
oh so this really is a decapitation
literally well we're going to put it
yeah yes
we're going to pay physicians per person
that they have in their practice and the
kind of building blocks of a capitation
system would be one a panel of patients
who are assigned to a doctor I say the
doctor might have a thousand patients
for which he or she is responsible we'll
call that group there their members
there their panel as you can call it
they're covered lives second piece of a
capitation arrangement is an agreement
about what the physician is going to be
responsible for under the agreement so
we might say it's primary care services
all the office visits and basic tests
and follow-ups that those patients might
need but maybe not their
hospitalizations or their expensive
surgeries right right you have some
group of patients you have some agreed
set of services and then you define a
payment which in the jargon gets called
the PMPM per member per month per member
per month and who is making this payment
it is the I guess the employer of the
doc so this this this definitely would
not be the case with a so it would be
the insurance company generally it's
going to pay the doctor this okay so an
insurance company let's say Blue Shield
Blue Cross Aetna Cigna any number of
different companies that might be out
there has an arrangement with a
physician that they take some some
number of their insured people are seen
by and become part of the panel of that
doctor they could arrange to pay that
doctor on a capitation basis I see I
saying you've got a thousand of our
patients here's what we're going to pay
you to take care of them I see and it
seems to make a lot of sense for the
insurance company because now you don't
have this incentive for the doctor to
you change the way the whole incentive
works so now if a physician gets say $25
per member per month for taking care of
their thousand patients they get 25,000
right month they've got to do what needs
to be done for those patients but they
don't get paid extra if they do
something additional if they do a more
expensive test as opposed to a poor test
they get paid the same amount so you
take away the incentive that exists in a
fee-for-service system that tends to get
people to try to do more things or at
least creates a world in which it's
possible to do more things and get paid
for it right is what the difference is
more predictable for the doctor to well
it could be predictable for the doctor
although in some sense it's predictable
and in another sense it's not an
important difference between for service
and capitation we'll say in health
policy is associated with risk or this
right of risk
and when we talk about risk here we mean
financial risk associated with the
health of the patients or variations in
the needs of the patients in a given
month so if you're a fee-for-service if
you're being paid fee for service the
doctor doesn't face any real risk if
it's a bad month everybody's sick
everybody needs lots of care they're
going to get paid for delivering that
care right i under kappa teh ssin the
doctor does face more of that risk
they're getting paid a fixed amount
right got to deal with whatever I see at
a high-volume month the doctor takes
that takes the hit in capitation but a
low-volume month the insurance company
takes it so it goes both ways it kind of
evens out right the insurance company
well no the doctor always the doctor
benefits in the low volume yes doctor
right kind of averages out in a good
arrangement this will be sort of even
over time the doctors look like okay but
these risk issues have been problems in
some capitation arrangements especially
if you're a small doctor practice and
you got a lot of variation from month to
month maybe you're not a great manager
you can get out you can go out of
business if you have a few bad months
who decides that it will be capitation
or fee for is it the doctor's choice or
the insurance company says this no you
will do this so over time it's been the
bid and negotiation back and forth so
insurance companies have preferences
about how they do this and doctors have
preferences about how this happens and
so sometimes some of it's driven just by
history the Medicare program for example
got started in the 1960s when
fee-for-service was the most common way
for ian's to be paid and that's largely
persisted in that program for historical
reasons it's very worked out that way in
the 1990s a lot of health plans decided
the insurance companies decided that in
the private market they'd like to do
more capitation right I did and they
started pushing these arrangements
trying to get physicians to agree they
were successful for a while and then
lately it's been a little more
physicians have said we don't like
capitation so well we'd rather go back
to fee-for-service that's working better
so the negotiation has gone Lize the
other way late have there been studies
that showed when you know doctors who
are competent under capitation do don't
order as many services or perform as
many services so the literature on this
is is pretty clear that it makes a
difference because you like to think
that it doesn't make a difference right
doctors most of them are all about the
help of the patient what well that's
right so there are there are hundreds of
thousands of doctors in the country
undoubtedly out there are some that pay
close attention to the financial
but I think actually you're right most
of them probably don't on a day-to-day
basis pay close attention you know at
the end of the year they'll see that
financials from their practice maybe
I'll think it through if you got to pay
college tuition that all of a sudden hey
maybe I'm our I wouldn't hurt or a
little extra this or that you know I
think that's part of it but the other
thing that I think is going on in the
background is the general maybe almost
subtle but things that you don't notice
that create a system and let a system
evolve in a regular way so doctors like
to do things for their patients patients
like to have things done for them a
fee-for-service system creates a world
in which everybody is fine with that you
know I can do that and so pretty soon
you get used to doing that right becomes
the first thing you think of right do
these extra things right neither party
neither the doctor nor the patient has
any intent of really of saying wait
right well pay for that although someone
else is okay and and you know it creates
in the background these incentives for
people who develop new products and
services right develop them and for it
makes it easy for a hospital say to put
in a big new piece of equipment that
they they're pretty sure they can pay
for and once it's sitting there and you
pass it every morning and right into the
hospital just becomes that much easier
to use it and so it sort of guides our
system the elation of our system in a
way that has led us to a point now where
we consume a lot of healthcare maybe
sometimes health care that we don't need
it's often health care that's beneficial
but it's all costly and so that sets us
up for the kind of dynamics and the
challenges we have to how common is
Congress we should talk about salary
before I talk about before we talk about
how common they are we can yeah we can
we can pick that up as we go along fee
for service and capitation have been
Epping and flowing frankly in at the in
the u.s. at the moment fee-for-service
is a very common way for people to be
paid and capitation is is declining
there are still a really so this is a so
you know fee-for-service was where
everyone started capitation kind of went
a little bit in vogue and and owns the
fan of it right the doctors not a fan of
the doctors were less of a fan and so
they've been the arrangements have been
shifting more toward insurance
arrangements that would use more
fee-for-service these days so the u.s.
is definitely I think majority
fee-for-service who decides what the
panel cut it sounded like the insurance
companies would pay for part of the
panel of a doctor would be under
capitation so this these kinds of
arrangements can in practice get kind of
complicated right all right the concept
of paying per head is clear but right
there will be variations that go on
so if you
change the scope of services you change
the arrangement if you have a primary
care arrangement for capitation that's
one piece but of course it leaves off
right you know the MRI or the surgery
and what would happen in those cases the
health plan would have an arrangement
for primary care services with some
doctors under capitation then they'd
have other arrangements with other
doctors they might say have a capitated
arrangement with some cardiologists I
say the cardiology or they might have an
arrangement with some cardiologists to
pay fee for service to those crisis is
the one that's big mixed-up but
obviously there's an incentive if you do
if you are being paid capitation you
want the healthiest people in your in
your in that capitation panel so there's
another incentive it's in the background
right that's right selection kind of
excited and so you know it's again a
thing I think doctors probably don't
think about this right those doctors on
a day-to-day basis right but it's a
subtle force operating in the background
if you're pink if you're getting
capitation and you can take actions that
would get you right healthier patient
but right for that same $25,000 say you
end up a little bit ahead at the end of
the month and doctors don't I think like
to shift patients off and there's laws
that prevents or all kinds of activities
but subtly in the background it helps
system evolve in that drought that's
right oh we probably face about 11,000
okay and salary is what we imagine I
mean so most of us get paid salaries
what you imagine it's agreement to be
paid a certain amount per year for some
amount of working but this would this
also this would be from the insurance
companies would it so what happens we
talk about these three is being
different things but when you get to the
real-world interpretation or real-world
looking at systems that are out there
what you'll see is often mixes between
these and so the one of the pieces is
one of the pieces of disentangling this
is multi level systems and that's where
salary becomes kind of important to
think about so one common thing that
happens as physicians grouped together
into larger practices right and that
larger practice collects the activity of
all the doctors that work in that
practice right bills for that from an
insurance company and then disseminates
there distributes them right among the
doctors and so what you will often see
in real life and that complicates the
inference here is say a large practice
that build an insurance company on a
fee-for-service basis right the
collective activity of all the doctors
takes that resulting pool of money and
divides it up maybe pay some of the
doctors a salary maybe pays them a
salary with some sort of bonus that
depends on how much work they did and
does other things
so sometimes the incentive that an
individual doctor sitting in a room with
a patient is looking at might be
different than the instead of facing the
mandatory practice who may then want to
get the doctors to do something that's
different than but the general idea is
if you're the only way to get a salary
so there's some organization between the
doctor and the insurance companies to
kind of yes insulate the doctor so the
important piece one of the important
pieces here that we think about is that
fee-for-service works in almost any
physician practice a solo practitioner
one person working by themselves or two
together could do this capitation almost
always works in any kind of physician
practice right with the exception that
if you're a very small practice the
rescue phase for two month depending on
the sickness of your patients might put
you out of business if you're not really
on top of it right so we like to think
capitation could work in any practice
but really only larger ones and salary
is a nice incentive and a lot of ways
but requires you to have a big
organization to be able to do this and
so some of the differences you see and
how physicians get paid have a lot to do
with the size of the organization they
work it makes complete sense well thanks
for that